بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد فاسال الله تعالى ان يبارك
لي ولكم في القران
العظيم اساله تعالى ان ينفعني واياكم بما
فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم اللهم علمنا
منه ما جاهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا وعلمنا
الحكمه منه اللهم انا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان تغفر لنا
وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت بعبادك
فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين اللهم
احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا وتوفنا اذا
كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم امين ثم اما
بعد
ف وصلنا الى فصل مهم
جدا وهذا الف فصل يعتبر من محكم هذا
الكتاب جميع ما يلي هذا الفصل من زاد
المعاد فانه يفهم على ما سنقرا في هذا
الفصل كيف
ذاك هو ياتي بهذا الفصل ابن القيم رحمه
الله وهو فصل في ترتيب هديه مع الكفار
والمنافقين من حين بعث الى ان لاقي الله
عز وجل
فالان يفصل لنا
بعموم
كيف تصرف صلى الله عليه وسلم
مع اصناف من الكفار من المعاهدين
والذمي
وال
الحربيين
وكذلك كيف تصرف مع المنافقين وكيف تصرف مع
المؤمنين
في ياتي بهذا الفصل ابن القيم رحمه الله
ثم بعده يسوق مغازي النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ويذكر غالب احواله في المدينه كيف
كانت احواله
والوقائع والامور التي دارت في المدينه
فهذا الفصل جميع ما
سنقرا من المغازي
والحوادث والامور التي كانت في المدينه
فاننا نفهم جميع
ذلك بناء على ما سنقرا في هذا الفصل لانه
يقعد لنا هنا قواعد اصول الاصل في التعامل
مع المعاهدين الاصل مع التعامل في التعامل
مع الذميين الاصل في التعامل مع المحاربين
الاصل في التعامل مع المنافقين الى غير
ذلك فهو فصل مهم
بمكان له
اهميه في غايه
الاهميه زد
المدن
ال non
‏and
was
circumstances from when he was first
sent aeng all the way until he was tak
الله سبحانه
وتعالى عليه الصلاه
والسلام ابن القرح الله
‏have very very detailed accounts all
the things that happen in med and
important for
us this chap because
follows is going to beer to this chap
علس ty
hit will and drive and are very easily
persuaded by the hypocrites there is
also difference between them also the
various types of disbelievers there were
agressive disbelievers they were
antagonizing disbelievers
there those who chose isam
‏harm muslim help against there
different people different types people
and how he
generally dealt with each type of person
in which tye of situation and so
anything that we read after this chapter
we are to understand it through the lens
of this chapter here يقول ابن القيم رحمه
الله اول ما اوحي اليه وهذه قد قرانها
من قبل هذه الفقره وطنب في شرحها
لكن لا باس
ان نعيد
النظر في هذه الفقره يقول اول ما اوحي
اليه رب ما اوحى اليه ربه تبارك وتعالى ان
يقرا باسم ربه الذي خلق وذلك اول نبوته ثم
ثم انزل عليه يا ايها المدثر قم فانذر
فارسله بها يعني كما يقول
العلماء نبئ بقرا وارسل بالمدثر
نبئ
بقرا وارسل بالمدثر يعني لما انزل الله
تعالى عليه اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق خلق
الانسان في من علق
فانه كان نبيا حينئذ والنبي هو الذي يوحى
اليه بشكل عام وقد يؤمر بالتبليغ وقد لا
يؤمر وما امره بابلاغ احد ما امره بشيء
وانما اوحى اليه واصبح
نبيا فاوحي
اليه ثم ارسل بالمدثر لما انزل الله عليه
بعد موت
ورقه يا ايها المدثر قم فانذر حينئذ ارسل
كان رسولا لان الله امره قم
فانذر لذلك لما تقرا في كتب التاريخ كتب
التراجم تجد ان كثيرا من علماء الحديث
والمؤرخين لم يذكروا ورق ابن نوفل رضي
الله عنه لم يذكروه
في سياق الصحابه في عداد
الصحابه لماذا
لانه امن بالرسول صلى الله امن بالنبي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم لكن لم يكن ارسل
بعد وانما نبئ فجاءه وساق اليه الخ ساق له
الخبر فاقره واخبره بالخبر الحديث المعروف
في الصحيحين حديث عائشه ثم ما لبث ان
توفاه
الله ثم بعد
ذلك ارسله الله يا ايها المدثر فلذلك
العلماء يعتبرون اول الصحابه من اول
الصحابه من الرجال ابو بكر الصديق ومن
النساء خديجه ومن الشباب علي
ومن الرقيق او العبيد زيد بن حارثه وهل
مجره ولم
يذكروا ورقه لهذا السبب ليس لانه لم يؤمن
او ليس بمسلم بل جاء في بعض الروايات ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم راى في بعض ما
راى بعض ما اوحي اليه عن راى
ورقه في الجنه وانه محسوب من
اهلها رضي الله تعالى
عنه ابن
القيم
الله صلى الله عليه
وسه العلق
‏commed him in verses اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق rec in the name of your
lord who has created all things and has
created the human being from a clot aing
cl of bl so with this the propet صل الله
عليه وسلم was a
propet a
prophet is a general ter aeng
‏a prophet is any who has
been communicated with by vi revelation
when they rece revelation from this is a
prophet but mering revelation from allah
does not me that they have been sent to
others
‏awaken seng to them spoke them what
have and
so اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق that with this he was appoint a
propet appo as a prophet and then when
he later sent to
him يا ايها المثر ق فانذر
اسلام مج الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم تقراون في كتب السيره وقد انتشرت هذه
بعض الروايات
ان كان ثم انقطاع في الوحي وهذا
شيء
معروف جاء في حديث عائشه رضي الله عنها في
الصحيحين
ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم انقطع عنه الوحي بعد ان اخبر ورقه
وبعض بعد هذه
الايات اول خمس ايات من سوره
العلق والعلماء اختلف في المده التي كانت
بين
بين اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق وهذه التي
كانت هذه الحادثه في غار
حراء وما
كان
من قوله تعالى يا ايها المدثر فقيل بعض
ايام قيل بعض اسابيع وقيل ثلاثه
سنوات هذه الروايه
انتشرت وهي روايه ذكرها ابن هشام رحمه
الله في سيرته انه مكث ثلاث سنوات بين وفي
اسانيد ترجع
هذه المقوله الى ابن عباس لكن فيها
ضعف
انه جاءه
جبريل فقال له اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق خلق
الانسان من ع
ثم انقطع
الوحي وكان انقطاع الوحي
مدته ثلاث سنوات مكث ثلاث سنوات ثم جاءه
يا ايها المدثر قم
فانذر وهذا قول ضعيف
جدا مع شهرته منتشر ومشهور جدا لكن قول
ضعيف جدا لان
المؤرخين اجمعوا على ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
اعتكف في غار حراء وقضى العشر الاواخر من
رمضان في غار حراء مره واحده هذا باجماع
باجماع علماء السيره
ومؤرخين فاذا كان ثلاث سنوات بين اقرا
باسم ربك الذي خلق خمس ايات ثم انقطع
الوحي ثلاث سنوات لا يعقل انه لم يرجع الى
غار حرا لم يرجع ويعيد العزله في غار حراء
وانه كذا هذا قول ضعيف جدا بل الصحيح ان
انقطاع الوحي كان بضعه ايام يعني بجوز
اربعه ايام خمس ايام وقيل
ثلاث حتى تطمئن نفسه انا مساله عظيمه جاءه
ملك من الله اوحى اليه اقرا باسم ربك الذي
خلق قول قيل
ف فزع النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
لكن امهله الله سبحانه وتعالى بضعه ايام
حتى تطمئن نفسه تستقر نفسه يتاهب لاستقبال
الوحي مره اخرى فارسل الله اليه يا ايها
المدثر عائشه رضي الله عنها
صل الله عليه
وسلم اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق
العائشه خديجه رضي الله عنها
خديجه
خديجه ورل
‏who was a man who was a scholar of the
gospels and he had knowledge of he was
biling some narration
multilingual
and he explain to him
happened him
is الذي ان على
مو that
اللهه
that revelation seed
for break in revelation revelation the
عليه and he a while
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم mention that this break revelation
was up to years long three years and
اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق
خ passed break ration he years not any
comm الله سبحانه
وتالى يا ا
‏op rather the opinion also mention the
words was that this break in revelation
was only a few days and the reason for
that was so that he could cm down and
col him in order to
prep from allah سبحانه وتعالى يقول
فارسله بها ثم امره ان ينذر عشيرته
الاقربين
‏so he was generally apped as a
messenger and in this stage
he coned the m of isam spoke isam
to people in private his close
associates his friends people that he
knew he would people he in his
reles he would speak
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
of he commed him to
invite his
cl
cl فانذر قومه ثم انر من حوله من العربي
توسعت الدائره دائره الدعوه ثم انذر العرب
قاطبه ثم انذر
العالمين فاقام ب سنه ينذر بغير قتال و 13
سنه في مكه قبل الهجره ينذر بغير قتال
ويؤمر
بالصبر ثم اذن له في
الهجره ثم اذن له في
القتال ثم امره ان يقاتل من قاتل
ثم امره ان يقاتل المشركين حتى يكون الدين
كله
لله صل الله عليه
وسلم
isam was comm toite
‏to invite the entirety of his people
which would be the people of me then he
was commanded to invite all of the arabs
everyone in the arab peninsula to islam
whom he could conve the mage of islam to
and usually this would happen during the
season after this he was command to call
all of and
all to is and
‏began to write his messages and to
write his letters to the various kings
and emperors and rulers throughout the
known world at that time in the later
years of his time in medina ابن say 13
years where he was commed call islam and
he was not all to use force ‏in any way
violence or force whether it
be to fight back as a defense or
offensive no violence at all no force
and he was commanded to merely be
patient this was during his time in me
after this he was alled commed make
hij after this after he establ in he was
then all to use force ‏when
necessary then he was
commanded to use force against those who
use force against him and his
companions then he was commanded to use
force to spre islam as far and asly
as musl became an establ gover force
they are the governors of the air
peninsula
استبل يقول ثم كان الكفار معه بعد الامر
بالجهاد
ثلاثه اهل
هدنه واهل حرب واهل ذمه ثم كان الكفار معه
بعد الامر بالجهاد
ثلاثه اهل هدن واهل حرب وا اهل
ذمه وهذه الاقسام واضحه يقول فامره ان يفي
لاهل الهدنه ما استقاموا ما استقاموا يعني
ما
كانوا يوفون
بشروط الهدنه ما استقاموا يعني ما كانوا
مستقيمين على الاتفاق فان
خاف نبذ اليهم
فان خاف منهم
خيانه اذا
راى اذا
راى
ان اهل
هدنه من بينه وبينهم اتفاق وهدنه راى
انهم وكانهم
سيخون فانه امره
ان ينبذ اليهم على
سواء يعني يعلن لهم ويخبرهم الهدنه التي
بيننا وبينكم هي منتهيه يعلن لهم ان هذه
الهدنه
منقطعه لماذا لان الله تعالى يقول ان الله
لا يحب
الخائنين لانها
خيانه والخيانه من اقبح
اوصاف ما هي
الخيانه
الخيانه ان يبطش او
ينتقم ممن اشعره بالامن قل انت امن ثم
ينتقم
منه هذا هذه اسمها
خيانه
والخيانه لا يحبها الله
ولذلك فان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اخبر ان كل خاء يوم
القيامه ترفع له رايه عند
استه يقال هذه خيانه
فلان يعني كل واحد خان اخر سواء خان زوجه
او خانت زوجها او خان شريكه او خان عدوه
فان الله تعالى يرفع له علم يوم القيامه
يكون مكتوب عليها هذه خيانه
فلان لان الحق لابد ان يحص حصله سبحانه
وتعالى هو الحق ويظهر الحق وينصر الحق
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
فالخيانة لها
احوال لكن
الخيانه الخيانه مذمومه
باطلاق وفي بعض الروايات عن النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم انه يوصي بعض اصحابه ولا
تخن من خانك ولا تخن من خانك الخيانه تكون
من افشاء سر هذه نوع خيانه واحد يجيك بسر
والله يا فلان كذا وكذا بس ما تحكيش
لحدا ثم يفشي هذا السر او يحكي لحدا فانه
قد خان ما وعد هذه خيانه الخيانه تكون من
هذا الى ما
فوق حتى ان المسلمين والعلماء من تعظيمهم
للامانه ومن تقبيح
للخيانه كانوا لا يقبلون الروايه
من يكون في نوع خيانه
للحيوانات
تصدقوا جاء هذا عن الامام احمد رحمه الله
ارتحل الى راوي للحديث ياخذ عنه وتعب في
رحلته فلما وصل عنده
الرجل مد
يده
واشعر الدابه كان زي فر او ما شابه ذلك
اشعرها انه بده يعطيها قمح او شيء فلما
جاءته اخذ بالازمه ولم يعطها شيئا فترك
عنه الروايه راى ان هذا قد خان حتى للدابه
هذا لا يؤتمن فليس امينا على حديث رسول
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم حتى ان
الفقهاء رحمهم الله في كتبهم
يذكرون ان العهد ينعقد بمجرد
الالتفات ايش يعني واحد يجيك يحكي لك كلمه
وتراه
يلتفت قبل ما يحكي لك الكلمه هذا الان
سر هذا الالتفات يدل على ان هذا لا يجوز
افشاء الا
باذنه هكذا
كان
المسلمون س الله تعى
التق those we say disb we mean those
isam however they chose not
isam they disb meaning they
reation isam
isam and then
‏refuse that
invitation the people who refuse that
invitation three
types tells us the first are those who
had a treaty a peace treaty between the
muslims and
themselves then there was a second
type groups
[Silence]
‏against prop الله عليه
وسلم and so not only they refuse enter
islam choice but they also refused any
kindy
‏and so
they to as
agress against the musl
state these
indiv as ح they considered to
be
agress in in modern terms
us
ifd ty
اهل اهذ
are did not ac
islami their respective fai
however they chose to pay
the obligatory tax the
gizia in order to be considered part of
the muslim state so when person pays j
‏this tax they pay this and they
receive they paying for a service they
paying for a citizenship they are now
considered a part of the muslim state
they are under the safety of the
muss all of the resources of the muslims
that are avilable to look out for
their interest
‏will be exercised in order to keep them
safe so they are considered part of the
muslims or we say part of the muslim
state and
so with regards to those who he had a
treaty
with those
who rejected to enter islam they didn't
want to enter islam but
they agreed to a treaty a peace treaty
between themselves
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله all of the stipulations of treaty
as long as they continue to
ed صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏to
back
to not fulfill or a against the muslims
which part of the treaty he was
commanded
to clearly notif them that he is no
longer obliged by the treaty between
‏this is important
point and that is that الله سوره
الفال that they are going
to be
trous in their end of the treaty
use عليه
‏that
hearly proclaim to them and to notif
them that the treaty that we once had is
no
longer noer
up and that is the prop صل الله عليه
و do not
‏with are with
you someone sts you in the back you
don't get them back in back this is one
of the worst traits that a person could
have in general the prophet الله عليه
وسم men the people of
trey
those
give the feeling
‏they give the
notion of
safety and they use that in order
to be
treacherous with their enemy or friend
that any person who does this on the day
of judgment will have a flag banner
raised behind
him and
‏trey
isc
lowly tra to
have and the thing about trey is that
always it's usually beneficial to the
person who right why do people
cheat to
ahead competing with
‏another and then i agree with them he
you know let's take a break and then i
use that in order to get
ahead this
treachery is something
that is usually beneficial to the tre
this is why they do this they play on
both sides and unfortunately in our time
this is this is looked at as a kind
of skill ‏you know books are written on
how to be tre very well how
to you know get ahead get ahead by
stabbing people in the back and stepping
on their heads get high and to get ahead
and so on and so forth and the idea is
it's just playing a game of chess
nothing wrong with that right it's
just the game is played nothing personal
يقول وامره ان يقاتل من نقض عهده ونزلت
براءه ببيان الاقسام الثلاثه فامره بقتال
اهل الكتاب حتى يعطوا الجزيه وامره بجهاد
الكفار والمنافقين فجاهد الكفار بالسيف
والمنافقين الحجه وامره بالبراءه من عهود
الكفار وجعلهم ثلاثه
اقسام
قوله فامره بقتال اهل
الكتاب حتى يعطوا
الجزيه هذه مساله اختلف فيها
الفقهاء وذلك هل
الجزيه مقصوره على اهل الكتاب ام الجزيه
عامه في جميع اصناف
الكفار يعني هل الجزيه تكون
للمشركين هل الجزيه تكون للمجوس هل الجزيه
تكون لليهود والنصارى فقط والصحيح من
اقوال
العلماء ان الجزيه
عامه وان
كانت معوده لاهل الكتاب اكثر من المشركين
لكن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كما في صحيح
البخاري من حديث ابن عباس اخذ الجزيه من
المجوس
والمجوس قوم ليسوا من اهل الكتاب اجماع
العلماء عباد
النار ف كون النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقبل الجزيه من المجوس ف مشركي
العرب كان قبول الجزيه منهم
اقرب
واولى فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر باخذ
الجزيه من من الكفار بشكل عام لكن جاء
اللفظ في
القران حتى يعطوا الجزيه عن يدم وهم
صاغرون في اهل
الكتاب وهذا اللفظ
هو لان اقرب واحرى الناس بالجز هم اهل
الكتاب
طبع المشركين انهم لا يقبلون هذا وطبع
العرب عباد الاصنام واعداء المسلمين في
ذاك الزمن انهم لا يقبلون ان يعطوا
الجزيه وكان اهل الكتاب هم اكثر من يدخلون
تحت
هذا تحت هذا الشرط وتحت هذا الحكم فلذلك
جاء اللفظ بذكر اهل الكتاب لكن ليس س يعني
هذا انه مقصور على اهل الكتاب في
الراجح وهذا هو وهذا هو الذمي الذمي هو
غير المسلم الذي يك في بد
المسلمين يعي الجزيه كان من اهل
الجزيه حمايه المسلمين بشروط
باحكام و
عليه خدمه
للمسلمين ولدول المسلمين كدول تهم يعني
كاي شعب يتعاونون في مصالح
شعبهم ان شاء الله نكتفي بهذا القدر والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله